you do spend ten times as much time
advocating your point of view as you do
actually writing you are basically the
full guy and that is the role of the
screenwriter I was going there is no
reason ever to panic on this film
because the outcome of the movie is so
profoundly satisfying one character from
one story will meet another character
from another story and both of them will
have been profoundly influenced by the
third story and the meeting will have an
effect on both their lives I said is it
just can't go wrong language actually
has a function in film and its function
in film is to work alongside image and
this idea that you produce a film which
is pure by reducing it simply to images
is complete nonsense the first thing you
have to do as a screenwriter is to close
the dream down you have to make it
something so that everybody will accept
that there is some common direction in
which everybody is moving the next stage
is opening it out and making it possible
for other people to do wonderful things
we went for lunch together and Michael
said this is not how I saw the form at
all I saw it as a fast with steve coogan
and i said i didn't see it as a fast
with steve coogan i saw it as a serious
film about british complicity in torture
the producer said I'm sure you two will
eventually be able to argue it out and
to see eye to eye and michael is a
really bright lovely guy he just didn't
know i didn't think we ever will see eye
to eye I said I didn't think either
which we just have lunch it seems to me
all the interesting filmmaking that's
going on at the moment not all but I
most of the interesting film making is
either to reinvent your completely or to
work outside genre and so all the all
the all the stuff that's interesting is
breaking genre